let's stick with the phones let's go to
our caller from the three zero one area
code caller from 301 introduce yourself
and you can go right into your question
hi David good afternoon my name is Kevin
and I'm Washington DC great yeah and I
would like to ask you a question about
Jeff Sessions recently appointing a
prosecutor to investigate DOJ and FBI
potential violations and I'm just
wondering if you think there's any merit
to those allegations and I think that
it's completely legitimate to question
the behavior of any law enforcement
intelligence agency the President of the
United States senators police officers
members of the military all is perfectly
fine we need to have checks and balances
that extend to everyone particularly
people in government my concern about
that appointment by Jeff Sessions is
that it's hard to believe that it's a
sort of unbiased and fair appointment in
the sense that a lot of what sessions
has a problem with the FBI doing relates
to the Trump Russia investigation
sessions is recused from the Trump
Russia investigation and so sessions
choosing to appoint someone to partially
investigate the behavior of the agency
carrying out the Trump Russia
investigation is very very suspect for
me and I think that it would be much
better if it were a special prosecutor
from what I've been reading it doesn't
seem like it's really going anywhere for
now Kevin but that doesn't mean it won't
right that that does that just mean bar
so far but yeah I definitely have some
concerns about that and I think the last
person who should be deciding who
investigates the FBI is Jeff Sessions
that's for sure
right and the last question that I would
like to ask you is as you know Trump has
been pushing sessions hard to the point
special counsel in part because he wants
to paint the FBI as bias against them in
regards to Russian investigation and
since he didn't appoint Special Counsel
do you think Jeff Sessions job is
potentially at risk listen at this point
it seemed like Jeff Sessions has been so
close to getting forced to reside resign
or fired or resigning or whatever and
then he seems to come back I'm no longer
making any predictions about sessions
because it's just you know it seems to
go it's like a yo-yo it goes back and
forth I wouldn't be shocked if he goes
but I have no idea what's gonna happen
with the guy okay
thank you David all right thanks
appreciate the call today's episode of
the program is made possible in part by
Cody which is an innovative new
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that wants to revolutionize how
we send and receive online payments cody
stands for currency of the internet and
the goal is to build an infrastructure
for online payments that simple
transparent trustworthy instantaneous as
well as scalable and today's payment
solutions have a number of different
trust and usability problems whether
it's between consumers or between
businesses or between consumers and
businesses and Cody wants to solve a lot
of those problems through their currency
and platform which unlike a lot of the
cryptos and block chains that are out
there have actually been created
specifically and solely to be used for
payments cody has set out to do this by
using innovative base layer protocol in
the form of a directed acyclic graph
based ledger built from transactions
connected through time by harnessing
trust based algorithms if you're
watching this on youtube you can find
out more about cody and their initial
coin offering in the links below this
video this is not financial advice and
everybody should do their own research